bonjour je suis désolé mon fils au
timing parfait toute façon j'aurais pas
laisser isabelle faire ça vous êtes là
quelqu'un d'extraordinaire gilles vous
allez allez vous préparer parce que vous
êtes le plus court agents puissent y est
donc c'est bien que ça tombe sur vous
c'est vous qui allez faire l'homme canon
dans un instant on va revoir voilà dans
un instant là c'était un monsieur là ce
sera vous gilles comment vous
sentez-vous gilou très mal très mal
manger nous et ça me paraît compliqué
mais je vais essayer de vous propulser
une bonne nouvelle quand même c'est que
tu seras dans l'air tu vas pas sortir la
merde